welcome back i think this is so cool
bally's is giving you the key to the
cabinet of curiosity i unlocked it
earlier today so let's discover what's
inside
imagine exhibitions is for the curious
and they've opened up their newest
experience their third experience here
at bally's you guys have really taken
over this floor you have real bodies not
geo but those are family friendly this
one is for the 21 and up introduce us to
the cabinet of curiosities mckenzie so
we have entered the bar lounge in
speakeasy space for the first time here
in las vegas and the cabinet of
curiosities is the one and only of its
kind here in the market what we do here
is we introduce you to all of these
oddities
and on our coasters we have what's
called the curiosities catalog you'll
scan the qr code and then you'll go
around and find a number that's
associated with any of these oddities
and a story will be told you'll hear of
its travels or even a fun quirky
background i love it and they're such
beautiful trinkets too
all vintage okay so you can obviously
sit here hang out with your friends have
a drink you know talk about the
curiosities in the cabinet but you can
also enter the speak easy within the
speakeasy so let's go over here there's
a nice old-fashioned phone to get you in
the spirit
hello
hey this is rocky with her reservation
for two
okay
there's a special code
hello
password
las vegas now
[Music]
nice
it works tell us tell us where we're
going all right so we're entering the
safe room so this is the entrance to our
lock speakeasy
and this is our locksmith
kristin i'm coming to you now okay so
tell us how this works when we come in
here i see your outfit is very
prohibition very own brand yeah so um in
this room you're gonna have to
try to get to our speakers you're gonna
go through a series of locks and uh once
you're able to do that just pass these
doors it'll give you an experience uh
taking you back to the days of
prohibition where speakeasies were
thriving oh my gosh okay you see the big
door here but i just want to point out
this is also a door we're not going to
go through that one though so let's go
through here i've already unlocked the
code because i'm not going to give you
all the secrets you have to come to the
cabinet of curiosities to do it yourself
okay
so let's come in here hey guys getting
the bar ready so welcome us mckenzie
what are we doing in here for this
experience so in here this is our lock
speakeasy and here is the traditional
think of it as the prohibitionaire
cocktails the mcsolid
that's what you're going to experience
in here
even the decor everything it just takes
you back in time and i hear there's a
special unique experience you can do as
well with
another coaster with the code that's
right so once you enter here you'll
actually enter a different menu so this
is a twist on all of our prohibition
cocktails but then there is also a twist
to that which is the secret menu
i love that okay so how can people come
down and experience this so we ask that
you go to thecabnetlv.com
you'll find the keyhole and that's where
you'll make your reservation
okay we are in